Razors ultra thin blade laptops are
generally considered to be in a league
of their own when it comes to industrial
design they are the most powerful or
most affordable gaming laptops in the
market but the hardware that razors
engineers managed to cram into such a
sleek chassis without damming it to
overheat is a commendable feat the
exterior looks nearly identical to past
blades but why mess with a good thing
razor whether intentionally or not has
created a gaming laptop that resembles
Apple's MacBook laptops I'll be it with
a modest amount of gaming Flair a Razer
logo here and some green lights they're
the only tells that this is a product
meant for gamers but that's a good thing
the black anodized aluminum chassis
feels a lot better than the plastics
used for most gaming laptops and it
gives the blade an air of class that
most gaming products lack the latest
1080p version of the blade is priced at
$2,000 packing a gtx 970m mobile GPU
from Nvidia with three gigabytes of RAM
and a quad core intel core i7 processor
with a maximum clock speed of 3.6
gigahertz while not the pinnacle of
portable gaming tech the full HD blade
packs enough power to run most of
today's most demanding games at a decent
framerate with max or near max settings
BioShock Infinite ran really smooth at
Ultra settings hitting an average of 88
frames per second while running the
built-in benchmarking tool with tress-fx
enabled Tomb Raider can be a demanding
game but the blade was able to handle
tress-fx Ultra settings and FX AAA while
generating an average frame rate of 55
frames per second with a few small
compromises it's a cinch to get it
running above 60 frames per second Metro
last light is particularly challenging
even for the strongest gaming race we
had to disable a few advanced features
including tessellation super sampling
anti-aliasing and advanced physics but
we were still able to hit 60 frames per
second on average with ultra settings
battlefield 4 on office settings start
pretty well with Forex MSAA
averaging 55 frames per second during
gameplay while it's not a game unit in
heaven is a reliable benchmarking tool
designed to push hardware to the limit
with ultra settings including extreme
tessellation razor's blade fared quite
well averaging 34 frames per second
during our test the new 1080p blade
holds up really well under real-world
conditions while our current test proved
to be a capable gaming machine today
the three gigabytes of gddr5 vram will
be the first weak link in the chain as
PC games continue down the road of
larger textures and graphical bells and
whistles what's worse you aren't able to
upgrade the eight gigabytes of system
ram 8 gigabytes is a good amount for now
but not being able to install Ram may
prove to be a thorn in the side of some
people down the road other manufacturers
make it easy to swap RAM in and out of a
laptop but in order to keep the blade
Finn razor had to solder its memory
chips directly to its proprietary
motherboard of course there's also
something to be said for the blades
simple selection of connectivity ports
with only three USB ports HDMI out in a
combo headphone microphone port it may
leave some users wanting the lack of an
Ethernet port is the biggest issue we
faced as it made downloading today's
large games a longer process than it
should have been
while it's got a good Wi-Fi radio we
eventually reached for an Ethernet to
USB adapter for such a thin laptop the
blades battery lasts a reasonable amount
of time while it's untethered from
external power source we were able to
keep the blade alive for nearly four
hours while gaming and if you're keen to
use it for non gaming activities with a
slightly dim screen expect that number
to rise considerably as the Intel HD GPU
that lies within the core i7 CPU will
draw far less power than the discrete
NVIDIA GPU with a 256 gigabyte SSD the
blade can move a large amount of data
with ease but it doesn't necessarily
hold a lot of data a 512 gigabyte drive
would alleviate some of the space
constraints that occur when installing
multiple games to the blade but
unfortunately razer doesn't offer such
options on the full HD model it only
comes with 256 gigabytes so the new
blade is a capable portable and great
looking gaming laptop but more than ever
the blade is facing competition from
outsiders as is usual with razor's
laptops the decision to choose a blade
over something from the competition
comes down your appreciation for its
high quality chassis if you choose the
blade with all of its limitations in
mind you won't be disappointed it's not
the cheapest option around but it's not
always about comparing specs and numbers
when build quality is factored in here
the blade is the slickest gaming laptop
money can buy